Do hit the like button if you like this video
and subscribe to our channel for more such videos.
Hello and welcome to KnowledgeHut
Building a product successfully doesn’t
mean building a successful product.
create value for the customer, but building
a successful product does.
Therefore it is logical to aim at building
a successful product instead of aiming to
build a product successfully.
But before the arrival of Agile Manifesto,
this was not the case in the software industry.
Software development was being done by following
a rigid process, a lot of importance was given
to documentation, developers cared only about
following the contracts instead of caring
about delivering a useful product.
As the complexities of the products kept increasing,
so did the delivery time, what was being delivered
was not meeting customer expectations and
products were failing at a rapid rate.
Then in 2001, 17 software developers came
together to discuss possible lightweight methods
for software development.
They came up with a manifesto which had 4
values and 12 principles to make the software
development process more agile.
This manifesto is known as the Agile Manifesto.
These values and principles brought tremendous
improvements in the software development process
and now they are even being followed for the
development of non-software products, such
as computers, motor vehicles, medical devices,
food, clothing, and music etc.
In this video, we will be discussing the four
values given in the Agile manifesto one by one.
Individuals and interactions over process
and tools.
During the time of Waterfall method, a lot
of attention was given to the processes being
followed.
Waterfall method itself was a 5 step process
which had to be followed in order to develop software.
Following stringent processes used to make
the development process rigid and changes
could not be brought easily when required.
Additionally, a well-defined process is not
the answer to every problem.
No matter how detailed and well defined a
process is, there will always come some barriers
which couldn’t have been anticipated by
any process or tool.
Such barriers are overcome when individuals
sit together, discuss and find the solution
of the problems.
Also, innovation doesn’t come from rigid
processes but it comes from free minds.
This is why the Agile Manifesto says that
we should focus more on having competent people
working together effectively.
Process and tools should be used but only
until they are making things easy and effective
for us.
Working software over comprehensive documents.
The Waterfall method used to start with heavy
documentation process.
A lot of documentation used to be done before
even starting to build the software.
The features, specifications, layouts, requirements,
test cases etc were documented long before
their arrival time.
This approach had some drawbacks like, what
you have documented will be outdated by the
time you are done with it, you may end up
creating many features which may never be
used by the end user, the time spent on the
documentation of such features also goes in
vain.
Too much documentation also delays the project
which later becomes an opportunity cost for
the business.
Because of all these drawbacks, Agile Manifesto
favors working software over comprehensive
documents.
Instead of wasting a lot of time in creating
long documents and then taking feedbacks on
the basis of those documents, we should take
the feedback on the basis of working software.
A basic software with all the basic features
should be created first and then it should
be given to the end users and stakeholders,
then on the basis of the feedback received
from the users, further development should
be carried out.
In this way a lot of time is saved, also,
the created software has the features which
provide value to the end users
Customer collaboration over contract negotiation
In the traditional method of software development,
the customer was involved only at the beginning
of the project for contract negotiation, one
more time if there are any changes to be made
in the contract and finally at the end of
the project.
The development process was more focussed
on what is written in the contract instead
of being focused on what the customer wants.
This approach neglected the value of customer
feedback during the project.
When software is developed without the constant
feedback of the customer, the end result is
often a product which does not satisfy the
needs of the customers completely.
This is why the Agile Manifesto favours customer
collaboration over contract negotiation.
Agile emphasises on taking constant feedbacks
from the customer throughout the development
process so that whatever is being developed
is also being seen by the customer.
Whenever the customer feels that the project
is going in the wrong direction then he or
she can steer the project by providing inputs
to the developers.
Respond to change over following plan
Traditional software development methods were
not in the favour of change.
The traditional approach was to create detailed
plans in the beginning and then following
them throughout the project.
Being rigid does not only lead to the creation
of an improper product but it also makes us
miss the chances of bringing changes which
could make our product better.
This is why Agile manifesto favours responding
to change over following plans.
When software is developed with agility we
start with a plan which give us enough idea
of the direction towards we want to move.
Then as we proceed and see new events unfolding
in front of us we incorporate those realities
into the ongoing work.
New events are nots seen as obstacles but
anything new in our way becomes an opportunity
for us to provide additional value.
So these were the four values of Agile Manifesto.
Follow them in your project management to
ensure its success.
Don’t forget to subscribe knowledgehut and
visit our website for Agile related trainings.